thank you that's me
that's Shapiro I'm the executive
director of City meals-on-wheels quick
question how many of you live in New
York
I can see hands how many of you were
raised in New York much fewer I'm with
the hands down people
I am North Carolina raised by Brooklyn
parents Brooklyn and who said North
Carolina all right um graduated college
sold my car moved to New York with $500
in my pocket to find my fame and fortune
I wanted to go into advertising I wanted
to do account management it took a very
brief amount of time to get my first job
at Ogilvy as a receptionist not what I
wanted but I needed money I took the job
and to get into account management I had
to be a secretary so I'm older than 40
and I'm older than 50 that dates me was
on an old time typewriter ten fingers
really slow I could do it now I couldn't
be a secretary because I couldn't type
fast enough but if it was all thumbs now
I could do it I practiced I practice it
was not going anywhere very wise woman
our CFO started chatting with me and
said we have an opening as an account a
coordinator and I thought this is not
good the only class I nearly flunked a
chapel hill was accounting so I thought
I had to tell her I knew I had to tell
her because she was making a huge
mistake
and she said you can do this like all
right here we go she's like it is your
only path around typing so I did it and
I was pretty good at it and it helped me
learn the financial underpinnings of a
small organization which I now know is
quite important
worked my way through past accounting
and finally got into account management
where I was doing what I wanted to do
working with clients helping with
marketing and communications and it was
great
we're a 50-person organization at the
time 23 of us were let go in one day I
was one of those 23 not only did I not
have a job I had just charged a trip to
the Bahamas on my brand-new American
Express card for my boyfriend's birthday
so I had to pay for it figure that out
found a job quickly bounced around for
several years large agencies small
startups before there were startups and
realized at some point that it was a
very crazy life my kids were quite young
I was living in Westchester my husband
would put them in pajamas drive them
into the city to say good night to me
and take them back home my daughter's
here she can attest to that it was not
fun and I knew quickly that I couldn't
do it I left went to an agency up near
home in Westchester and was incredibly
happy eight years working with the
smartest people I could ever work with
but along the way killer hours still not
insane but killer I had clients in
London account in California at the same
time so bouncing through time zones
I think traveling my daughter probably
has could tell you every guilt gift from
every work trip that she ever received
and I knew I didn't like selling other
people's stuff I wanted to do something
with more meaning there was more
dysfunction it was time for me to go I
spent two years trying to get a non
profit job nobody thought my skillset
matched what they needed and it was hard
I left without a job thinking all right
I can focus on this six months of
searching in front of the computer or
sweats trying not to eat the pint of Ben
and Jerry's while the kids were at
school trying to figure out what I was
gonna do if this didn't work and another
woman took a chance on me the founding
executive director of City
meals-on-wheels was looking for a
director of marketing and communications
I got a job I thought it was going to be
a piece of cake the skills translate
they did I thought it would be easier
and it would be a softer environment it
was a business it is a business and
needed to be treated like a business and
I learned that quickly five years later
I took over as executive director city
meals is feeding homebound elderly New
Yorkers people too frail to shop for
themselves 60 and older 200 of them are
a hundred years old or over in this city
yes it is crazy and they will tell you
it's crazy if they're over a hundred but
I have never been more fulfilled the
path was not straight I have met the
people who built this city for you and
me and that was what was so meaningful
for me I did not have affinity towards
older people when I was young my parents
grew my grandparents died when I was a
teenager there was no connectivity and
that changed so quickly I have met Mary
who rode the elephants in Ringling
Brothers yep
Frederick designed the first leather
bomber jackets for the NYPD and Mamie is
my favorite my very first meal delivery
going out with a photographer to see
what we do we were in Brownsville
Brooklyn where my dad grew up
not great when my dad grew up and not so
great now
Mamie had lived there most of her life
her husband and daughter only daughter
had passed away her shoes were held
together with duct tape
she lived in a small dark apartment and
she was too afraid to go outside even if
she could but she had a sparkle in her
eye and we're sitting in her kitchen and
the photographer brought the camera out
and she sat up straight cocked her head
to the side and said should I strike a
pose that picture is still in my office
to this day it has changed Who I am and
moves me on a regular basis when I look
back and think 30 years ago would I have
ever realized or thought that I would
feel so fulfilled in my job I don't
think I would have but I've learned a
few things the path is not straight the
finance job was the best thing that
could have happened to me to be where I
am where I am now and to have that
knowledge I had great people who
believed in me sometimes even before I
believed in myself I mentioned two women
there were a lot of other women there
are a few men in there too but to find
people to mentor you I believe that
success does not come simply from hard
work it comes from trying to deliver
excellent work because excellence is
what breeds success and I think but yond
anything else it is to be genuine and
true to who you are I am a little bit
kind I say that's the North Carolina
still stuck in here after 30 years but
I've also realized I don't have to be an
ass to be a leader in New York City even
thank you it's true but to rely on your
circle to find your people
and to be true to who you are thank you
[Applause]